I don't know about you,
but I've noticed
a very welcome uptick recently
in the number of fantasy books
inspired by
West African folklore.
The Afrofuturism and
African futurism movements
have paved the way
for Black authors
across the diaspora
to build worlds
and tell stories influenced
by their heritage.
Thanks to the hit success
of books like Tomi Adeyemi's
"Children of Blood and Bone,"
wider audiences are finally
getting introduced to the orisha
and spirits of Yoruba lore.
But who are these deities,
and where do they come from?
[upbeat music]
In Adeyemi's novel,
the main character is part
of the Iku clan that
worships the deity Oya
and traditionally has
powers over life and death.
Oya is a real figure
from Yoruba mythology,
a collection of stories
from the widespread tribe
that speaks the Yoruba language.
Oya is one of many
orisha, or deities,
who can move between the
human and divine realms.
With control over the wind,
a reputation as
a fierce warrior,
and a responsibility
to watch over
the threshold of life and death,
Oya is one of the more
formidable Yoruba deities,
but she is by no means
the most powerful.
According to Yoruba mythology,
the universe and all
of the forces therein
were created by
a single supreme being,
most often known as Olofin.
Also known as
Olorun or Olodamare,
this genderless creator
god is all-knowing,
all-powerful and eternal.
It might be tempting
to compare Olofin
to the Abrahamic God, but
they are a unique being
and no other deity is like them.
In the beginning of time,
Olofin crafted the universe
and invented day and night.
They gave divine
energy called ase
to all the objects and beings
and breathed life, or emi,
into every living thing.
They did not, however, want
to manage every living thing,
so Olofin created the orisha
to act as intermediaries
between Orun, the
spiritual heavenly realm,
and Aye, the world of tangible,
visible things.
There are hundreds of
orisha in Yoruba folklore,
though it may be impossible
to give an exact count
because their characteristics
are malleable.
A single orisha's name,
gender, and parentage can vary
depending on when and
where you hear the story,
though their core traits
remain largely unchanged.
Some of the orisha, like
Obatala and Orunmila,
are primordial figures
who were involved
in the creation of the world.
Others like Oduduwa or
Shango, were mortal ancestors
whose deeds led them to be
deified into the religion.
And there were many
orisha who personified
aspects of nature like
the spirits who embody
the numerous rivers
and lakes in the world.
Before the world was created,
Olofin and the orisha
lived in the sky around
a young baobab tree.
Below them stretched
a vast ocean
ruled by the orisha Olokun.
Most of the orisha were
content to explore the sky
and enjoy a life of luxury
around their baobab tree,
but Obatala wanted more.
He looked at the vast
ocean below and thought,
"Hmm, I could make
something with that."
So he asked Olofin
if he could build
a resting place
for living things.
Olofin gave him
permission to make land,
but left it to Obatala
to figure out how.
Obatala went to Orunmila,
the orisha of
prophecy, for guidance.
Orunmila, whose power
of divination made him
the sole witness to Olofin's
creation of the universe,
told Obatala to fashion
a long gold chain,
fill a snail shell with
sand, and gather a chicken
and a date palm nut.
Obatala traveled the sky,
asking the other orisha
for their spare gold, which
he forged into a chain
to carry him to Olofin's ocean.
When Obatala climbed to
the end of the chain,
he found that he still
had some distance to go.
From his position in the
sky, Orunmila told Obatala
to pour sand from his
shell onto the ocean
and immediately
drop the chicken.
When it landed, the chicken
began to kick the sand around
until it formed a huge land
mass with hills and valleys.
Obatala jumped
down from his chain
and planted his date palm nut,
which immediately
sprouted into a full tree.
That spot became Ife,
the legendary cradle
of Yoruba civilization
that archeologists believe
was an urban center by 800 C.E.
Obatala made some wine
from the fruit of his tree,
and after partaking in
perhaps too many libations,
began to mold
people out of clay.
Many of the figurines
were imperfect,
with missing limbs
or unintended bends,
but Olofin breathed
emi into them anyway.
When Obatala saw his
creations come to life,
he vowed never to drink again
and assumed responsibility
for protecting humans
with physical differences.
In some stories,
Obatala got drunk
before he could complete
his task of making land,
and his younger brother,
the orisha Oduduwa,
took over for him.
Regardless of who made the land,
Yoruba lore tells
of Oduduwa, or Odua,
the first king of Ife from whom
the Yoruba people are descended.
Olokun was furious that her
ocean had been encroached upon
without her permission--not
even a heads up from Obatala--
so she sent great waves
to flood the land.
Those lucky enough to reach
high hills besieged Eshu,
the messenger orisha
of roads and doors,
to intervene on their behalf.
Eshu told Orunmila
about the flood
and he used Obatala's
golden chain to climb down
and cast spells until
Olokun's water retreated.
Notice that the
people begged Eshu
to take care of the flood,
not the supreme creator.
As the messenger orisha,
Eshu stands watch
at the boundary between
the realms Orun and Aye,
the two halves of
the Yoruba cosmos.
Eshu ferries notes and
sacrifices across the threshold
and looks over ritual practices.
According to a Yoruba saying,
If Eshu is not acknowledged
during a ritual, then
life is the bailing
of waters with a sieve.
In other words, if you're
not going to honor Eshu,
why even bother?
This makes even more
sense when you consider
that Eshu is the trickster
of Yoruba mythology.
Ritual sacrifice and prayer
are just two of the ways
mortals can connect to the
orishas' wisdom and power.
The other is through
divination that lets humans see
the universal forces that
influence their lives.
So Orunmila is the
other orisha who sits
between Orun and Aye
as Olofin intended.
Now, I don't know from
personal experience,
but any parent can tell
you that just because
you give a being
life doesn't mean
they'll always follow
your directions.
The orisha are no different,
and in one Yoruba myth,
they decided they were tired
of listening to Olofin.
What could a being who lived
so far away from the world
possibly know about
how to run it?
They believed they
could do a better job
maintaining the world without
Olofin's pesky influence.
Instead of punishing the
orisha for their disrespect,
Olofin held the rains
back from the world.
Rivers and lakes evaporated
away, crops withered,
and animals and humans
alike died of thirst.
They cried to the orisha,
as they had always
done when distressed,
"What have we done
to anger you?"
The humans never
imagined that it was
the distant creator god
who was causing their pain.
The orisha begged for
Olofin's forgiveness,
but their cries couldn't
carry far enough to be heard.
Many of the orisha tried to
reach Olofin's heavenly home
but they tired before
they reached it.
Beautiful Oshun, the
youngest of the orisha
who looks after the world's
sweet waters, wanted to try.
The other orisha were
skeptical that someone so young
could accomplish such
a difficult task,
but Oshun insisted.
She turned herself into
a beautiful peacock
and flew towards
Olofin's distant home.
As she flew, her feathers
began to fall off,
and as she passed the fiery sun,
her feathers smoldered away.
She flew and flew and flew
until she didn't think
she could fly anymore,
but she finally reached Olofin.
By the time she
collapsed at their feet,
Oshun's feathers were all gone.
Instead of a beautiful peacock,
she was an ugly vulture.
Olofin was touched
by Oshun's sacrifice,
by her courage and persistence,
and agreed to send the
rains back to the world.
For her troubles, Olofin
told Oshun that she alone
as a vulture could communicate
directly with them.
After this tale,
humans can commune
with the orisha through
Eshu, But anyone who wants
to reach Olofin must
go through Oshun.
Given her beauty and proximity
to the supreme creator,
it's no surprise that Oshun
was one of the wives of Shango,
the woman-loving orisha
of thunder and lightning.
Together, they produced
Ibeji, a pair of sacred twins.
To this day, twins are
special to the Yoruba
and mistreating them is
said to bring about misfortune.
In history, Shango was one
of the first Yoruba kings
who ruled from the
ancient city Oyo
and was closely
related to Oduduwa.
In mythology, Shango is
one of many who sprang
from the body of
the orisha Yemoja.
The orisha Shango
briefly occupied
the body of the mortal king,
but also took other forms
throughout his immortal life.
The human King Shango's
reign was harsh and violent.
Legend says that he
was so relentless
in his search for
power through magic
that when he finally
obtained dominion
over thunder and lightning,
he accidentally used it
to destroy his palace with
his wife and children inside.
Dismayed, Shango fled his
kingdom and hung himself,
but his mighty power
was not forgotten.
Shango was deified as an
orisha after his death
or should I say that his
identity as the orisha
was discovered after
the king's death.
Either way, King Shango's spirit
didn't follow the typical
path of other dead mortals.
Someone who lived a long
good life could expect
to join the ancestors
in Orun after they died.
If it was part of Olofin's plan,
they might be reincarnated.
Unlike Hinduism's
karmic reincarnation,
where a soul can return in
any number of random forms
based on their behavior
in a previous life,
atunwaye is the belief
that you will be
reborn into your own family.
Your actions in this life
determine your family's
future fortune.
So if you misbehave, you won't
come back as a cockroach.
You'll be born into poverty
as your great-grandson.
These stories and beliefs
from Yoruba mythology
are a small part of a
colorful, dynamic culture
that goes back
almost 2000 years.
They are preserved in
Isese, a Yoruba philosophy,
way of life and religion, which
is still practiced by many.
Today, there are roughly
50 million people,
spread between parts of
Nigeria, Benin, Ghana, and Togo,
who speak the Yoruba language.
Yoruba and Isese
influence can be seen
in Caribbean spiritual practices
like Santeria and Candomble.
But now that you know a
bit more about atunwaye,
the intervening orisha
and supreme Olofin,
I'm willing to bet that
you'll start to notice
West African influence
all over modern media.
But believe me when I say
I've barely scratched
the surface
of Yoruba mythology here.
So comment below with
your favorite stories
or figures from Yoruba lore
and don't forget to thank Eshu
before you hit send.
Before you go, if
you're a fan of this show,
there is a new
series on PBS Origins
called "Rogue History"
that we know you'll enjoy.
There is a mythology
surrounding pirates
that has infiltrated
our culture,
but how much of it is true?
"Rogue History" examines
pirate lore to unravel
historical myths,
unearth lost narratives,
and introduce you to
little-known characters.
It's the pirate history
you were never told.
Check out the link in
the description below.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.